[Music]
Karin a Quranic integrity costo de la
marine hoops for this from got me
Bhupati strong got this name is Ivana
Ganesh with hate about Tony I hunted
technology Joe get at the Mona hijita
don't drink issue up negative check-in
to send if you've ever to reconsider of
Nityananda and it ribbit ricotta
Nicastro cotton - Coco toasty teacher i
associated it happen arrested her last
needs in Jakarta banded Arizona worker
had a needed a look to worry what now
dr. Lerner hey Cass was it only could
tackle it occasionally
I can create a conditioner on igano not
a water cooler Negro tackle delicious
[Music]
when you shop for clothing on Amazon you
see a giant selection from many
thousands of sellers available for cheap
and swift delivery to your door it's
part of the reason Amazon has become one
of the largest apparel retailers in the
United States a Wall Street Journal
investigation found that Amazon sells
clothing from factories major fashion
retailers have blacklisted for unsafe
conditions that put workers lives at
risk
Amazon size and structure mean it has
less oversight of its supply chain than
its competitors in the apparel industry
traditional retailers build trust into
supply chain by checking who's
manufacturing their products where
they're sourcing the materials for it
Amazon marketplace has more than 500
million products which are sourced by
millions of different sellers and Amazon
doesn't know enough information about
them to enforce the same sort of tactics
traditionally the US would use an Amazon
spokesman said the company audits the
supply chains of its own brands and the
company's supply chain standards require
its suppliers to provide workers with a
safe and healthy work environment he
added that Amazon expects third-party
sellers to meet these same standards to
figure out where clothing items on the
site were coming from the journal
started with lists of unsafe factories
and a database of a billion shipping
records then untangled the web of
importers middlemen in Amazon sellers
this child's top was for sale on Amazon
buy a storefront called chilly pop when
you ordered it it shipped from a
clothing store called cookies in
Brooklyn New York but before that he was
imported by the owner of the chili pop
brand a wholesaler in New York's garment
district called trend set originals to
reach Manhattan he crossed the ocean in
a shipping container all the way from
Bangladesh where it was loaded on a ship
in the port city of Chittagong the major
export hub for Bangladesh is garment
industry
[Music]
in 2013 Bangladesh and its garment
industry were rocked by the Rana Plaza
tragedy and the world was briefly
attuned to where its clothing was coming
from the death toll from a bomber
factory building in Bangladesh that
collapse is climbing the collapse was
blamed on shoddy construction and a
disregard for safety regulations an
investigation found the workers had
complained about the cracks in the walls
more than 1,100 people were crushed to
death the 2,000 injured they were making
clothes for well-known brands when
factory collapse
everyone was pulling the body but I was
pulling the levels I was pulling their
clothes if we can't document who was
sourcing this factory they'll be totally
clean their hand and deny for any known
brand we definitely can write to them
but if it is go through the Amazon
how're we gonna make sure that who was
the brand who will be sourced from you
just cannot check down facing pressure
after Rana Plaza global retailers forged
agreements with Bangladesh as garment
industry like the Accord on fire and
building safety in Bangladesh the Accord
in similar groups inspect factories and
assist with safety improvements when
factories fail to improve unsafe
conditions they are listed as ineligible
to work with major brands like these US
brands and these brands from major
markets around the world if a factory
has been so poor in their efforts or
commitments to meeting the minimum life
safety standards of our inspection to
the point where the 200 global brands
that have signed the accord said we're
not doing
business with you for somebody to go and
manufacture at that facility with that
knowledge is unethical it's arguably be
criminal cookies director told the
Journal that its suppliers pledged to
use only safe factories and that cookies
would be taking action against trend set
originals a spokesman for trend said
originals said it's sourced from
Riverside Apparel's through a middleman
with whom they have cut ties factories
in Bangladesh with documented unsafe
conditions in theory should be barred
from accessing much of the US and
European retail markets but many have
found a backdoor from Amazon we know
that it's happening because we know that
the factories that we've made ineligible
they don't close so they're getting
orders from somebody other than Accord
brands The Wall Street Journal followed
the supply chain from a hundred and
twenty two factories blacklisted by the
Accord and similar groups that are still
in operation the journal
cross-referenced lists of the banned
factories with the database of a billion
shipping records then connected the dots
between the importers and Amazon sellers
the journal could only access records
for shipments sent directly from
Bangladesh to the United States but was
able to trace clothing items from fifty
one of the hundred and twenty-two banned
factories all the way to Amazon Amazon
removed these items after the journal
flagged them to the company an amazon
spokesman said the company takes action
against any third party seller they
learn is not meeting in supply chain
standards the toddler topped the journal
traced from Amazon was made at a
Chittagong factory called Riverside
Apparel's
that has been banned by the Accord for
unsafe conditions
so this is a structural report from an
initial inspection so this one highly
stressed columns the engineers
determined they were stressed because
there's toilet blocks above them this
one is a finding where there's damage to
the actual column itself at the base the
water tanks are weight that needs to be
considered in the capacity of water on
the roof has to do with the integrity of
the concrete and corrosion to some of
the rebars the ownership of Riverside
Apparel's would not let the Wall Street
Journal inside the film but they granted
an interview with their managing
director at their new factory in Dhaka
which has yet to be inspected by the
Accord not having an accord complete
Factory hurts the business to some
extent but then again you cannot have an
accord compliant factory right away it's
an ongoing process there are issues that
remains unsolved the tops were sewn by
workers at riverside and overseen by
supervisors like Roble and mehar one
Tamati Bobby safety hundred percent safe
table there now in terms of only severe
Baptists in the way Tony's electronic
donut yeah boy it is a tie yet happy the
ashleeta coburn a cattleman is against
hip
all right Monica don't Rama Plaza don't
consider talking to Monica got me sir
I'm at the Rana Plaza to blow a car
maracas in Austria C Mon Oregon miss
that's hurriedly mechanic he could
woman's kiss your ecology mentality put
it on the court also found that
Riverside of Parros has inadequate fire
safety measures when the Wall Street
Journal visited the factory these metal
gates were closed over the front and
rear exits while workers were inside the
Accord warns gates like these whether or
not they are locked could trap workers
trying to escape a fire or building
collapse and require factories to
replace them with hinged emergency exit
doors when asked about the metal gates
Riverside Apparel's owners said keeping
them closed was not the usual practice
the financial aspects of compliance is
pretty heavy obviously I don't want to
discuss the numbers but it's pretty
heavy manufacturers have the capacity to
do it many factories do not have the
capacity to do it
[Music]
it isn't easy for garment workers to
walk away from unsafe factories
Bangladesh's garment industry is the
country's largest employer and according
to the World Bank it's only growth
sector did am Reverend Bob Duggar didn't
do domestically once a I did the noble
citizen who believed I'm an economist if
to thoroughness of mm hello multiple
idea but deal patellas alderman easier
eggsy
[Music]
shut up damn okay - Dena say how many
nos asking what family take is he over
stomach ate a [ __ ] in Hamilton outside
John McCosker worry Annie Parish
shattered besought sacre-coeur see we
live an extracting or see definitely
sorry Gobber associated no sorry good to
see a commotion about the chocolate in a
[Music]
casket reject America's decided to see
the hell over if we take two baths on of
porcelain more pulley work a Scottish
image of the circle how new Ginoza
cosplay Amazon's competitors made
commitments not only to improve factory
safety in Bangladesh but also workers
rights now Amazon is overtaking its
rivals bringing new practices and
pressures to the apparel industry that
undermine these efforts ecommerce has
been showing a growth trend for the last
couple of years mostly what's been
selling through econ is fashion and
Amazon is one of the big players in the
market retailers they want to provide
the consumers with a variety of choices
I am having say for example 50,000
pieces to make but with 20 different
styles for that reason we have to find
ways in which we can increase efficiency
Busan there's a male Pokemon what one is
a producer and manager Bellamy almost
eerie
so Tarragona disabilities division
manager the whole the production Haneda
contract miserable reproduction Philip
could be draggin little too humble to
take a snap Alleluia oh yeah what could
I believe in a same as amazon's biggest
competitors in apparel chase its
e-commerce success they're having
similar issues keeping blacklisted
factories out of their supply chains the
journal traced clothing items from 22
banned factories to walmart most were
for sale on Walmart's third-party
Marketplace designed to mimic Amazon's
the journal also found garments from one
band factory listed online by target a
Walmart spokeswoman said the company is
investigating the items it sells
directly and will take appropriate
action target declined to comment but
remove the items after they were flagged
by the journal supply chain
responsibility is a major issue for all
companies but I think that the
e-commerce brands should pay the same
heat and make the same commitments to
supply chain responsibility buying from
the store and buying online is a two
different world these online store like
Amazon they are working with many of
those factories which has been
blacklisted by the Acorah if it is
continuous
you don't know maybe we're gonna see
another runner Plaza catastrophe
whatever cell multiplication pirata
Fonseca see a meter shot assume there is
a
quality below
to be able to reconstitute our opinion
on now is a tizzy or jeru the damaja to
reverse it with our water up to reverse
it
I'm Armando me auras are 100 theories
but Amazon
[Music]
you